[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance it is impossible to watch the
drip drip drip of Robert Muller's Russia
investigation the hourly drip drip drip
the weekly drip drip drip the monthly
drip drip drip it is impossible to read
the New York Times report that some
White House officials are privately
afraid that other White House officials
may be wearing wires to serve tisha Slee
record conversations for mr. Muller it
is impossible to review the reporting of
the last week and the reporting of as
long ago as last January and see how
nearly perfectly that reporting aligns
it is impossible to do all that and to
not conclude that the leaking ceiling
will soon or late cave in on Donald
Trump and in large part it will do so
because of Facebook first Facebook
confirmed it had sold more than 100,000
dollars worth of divisive advertisements
often filled with eight speech to a
Russian company linked to the Kremlin
during the election then the Wall Street
Journal reported that Facebook had given
Muller's team the ads that details about
who bought them and the methods used to
get them in front of specific Facebook
users the so-called targeting then CNN
reported Facebook had not done this
voluntarily that Muller had gotten the
judge to issue a warrant
meaning Muller convinced a judge not
merely that the Facebook ads included a
crime war crimes but he had to have
convinced that judge that evidence
supporting prosecution of the alleged
perpetrators could still possibly be
found in Facebook's files it would be
the computer equivalent of a paper trail
it is a federal crime for foreign
individuals or governments to contribute
to an American election campaign whether
by money or other means it is a federal
crime for an American election campaign
to knowingly accept such foreign
contributions it is a federal crime for
Americans to participate in that process
it is what we have colloquially called
collusion with Russia as the former
federal prosecutor Renato Marriott a
noted on Saturday quoting it it is a
crime to know that a crime is taking
place and to
but succeed that's aiding and abetting
if any Trump associate knew about the
foreign contributions that Muller's
search warrant focused on and helped
that effort in a tangible way they could
be charged in addition anyone who agreed
to be part of this effort in any way
could be charged with criminal
conspiracy they wouldn't need to be
involved in the whole operation or know
everyone involved this may seem complex
and new to you but this part of the trip
has been falling steadily since January
12th
that is when Paul would world affairs
correspondent for the BBC wrote and I
quoted him here last April 2016 the CIA
director was shown intelligence that
worried him it was allegedly a tape
recording of a conversation about money
from the Kremlin going into the u.s.
presidential campaign as wood also noted
in October 2016 the Department of
Justice was thus able to get a warrant
from a Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act court a FISA port they wanted
permission to intercept the electronic
records from two Russian banks
ultimately the investigation is looking
for transfers of money from Russia to
the United States each one approved a
felony offense a lawyer outside the
Department of Justice but familiar with
the case told me that three of mr.
Trump's associates were the subject of
the inquiry quote but it's clear this is
about Trump
he said that's Kremlin money reportedly
going into the u.s. presidential
campaign no later than April 2016 and an
inquiry touching three Trump associates
/ the reporting of the bbc's with Paul
Wood On January 12th of this year on
March 30th of this year Paul wood was
back with more this is a three headed
operation said one former Obama
administration official setting out the
case based on the intelligence firstly
hackers steal damaging emails from
senior Democrats secondly the stories
based on this hacked information appear
on Twitter and Facebook posted by
thousands of automated BOTS then on
Russia's english-language outlets RT and
Sputnik then right-wing us quote news
sites such as Infowars & Breitbart
than Fox and the mainstream media
thirdly Russia downloads the online
voter rolls the voter rolls oh yes
remember more than a year ago when
somebody hacked into and scanned the
voter registration computers in Arizona
and Illinois
remember ABC News reporting there were
attempted voter roll scanning hack seen
twenty different US states remember when
the Director of National Intelligence
said in a joint statement with the
Department of Homeland Security that the
hacking was done mostly from quote
servers operated by a Russian company
Russian servers which recorded names
party affiliations emails of voters the
voter rolls are said to fit into this
because of micro targeting using email
Facebook and Twitter political
advertising can be tailored very
precisely individual messaging for
individual voters Paul woods reporting
and sources were prophetic that is what
the developments of the last week
suggest the Russian end of this
perversion of our democracy must be but
is there an American end
is there anybody close to Trump
connected to Trump involved in the Trump
campaign who would have been involved
here in this country in micro-targeting
Forbes magazine December 20th 2016 the
beaming face of Jared Kushner this guy
got trump elected I called somebody who
works for one of the technology
companies that I work with and I had
them give me a tutorial on how to use
Facebook micro-targeting Kushner says by
June the GOP nomination secured Kushner
took over all data-driven efforts within
three weeks in a nondescript building
outside San Antonio he had built what
would become a 100 person data up
designed to unify fundraising messaging
and targeting the president's son-in-law
in charge of the Trump campaign digital
campaign and it's targeting and it's
micro targeting and there's one other
shoe also to drop again quoting Jared
Kushner we brought in Cambridge
analytical I called some of my
from Silicon Valley who were some of the
best digital marketers in the world
Cambridge analytical as I noted here on
April 3rd micro-targeting would be gold
to apolitical data mining company like
say Cambridge analytic a whose
vice-president and member of the board
is or was
Steve Bannon Cambridge analytic up to
five million dollars of the equity of
which is or was owned by Steve Bannon
Cambridge analytical which has its
headquarters in New York eight blocks
down from Trump Tower and learned since
March a major investor in Cambridge
analytic a Robert Mercer ultra
right-wing billionaire financier at
Breitbart and major backer of Donald
Trump one theory of this case seems to
be that the Russians committed acts of
international cyber warfare in order to
steal dirt on Hillary Clinton and
attempt to steal American voting rolls
and every available detail of every key
voter in every state then they allegedly
fed the material back to the Trump
campaign and bought the hundred thousand
dollars worth of targeted advertising on
Facebook and Bannon knew and Kushner
knew and Mercer knew and Cambridge
analytic anu and who knows maybe at that
Trump Tower meeting with the Russian
lawyer and Kushner and Paul Manafort and
Trump jr. maybe they all knew - and thus
maybe Donald Trump when he reportedly
wrote juniors cover story about
adoptions maybe he knew and now Robert
Muller knows I will stand by my
prediction we will wake up one of these
mornings and Trump will be retweeting
and other anti-semite or trying to
provoke a deranged foreign leader or
whining about somebody on television and
it will all seem nightmarishly normal
and then during the day there will be a
bunch of meetings at the White House
that will hear about featuring lawyers
and prosecutors suddenly appearing in
carload Lots and that night around 6
o'clock we will suddenly hear that Trump
is going to resign the following morning
and people will be surprised well some
of them will be resist remove peace